friends comrades in arms who fought the
Islamic State vocal critics of the West
immortalized in stone where they died
assassinated in a US drone strike four
years ago here in Bagdad Iranian
commander kasum sulamani and Iraqi
paramilitary leader Abu Mahi al-
muhandis still walk hand in hand doves
encircle the wreckage of their bombed
out cars there is no mistaking the close
bonds of cooperation between Bagdad and
tahran which is why Iraq's government
says onon air strikes on her bill
earlier this week against what it
described as separatists and Israeli
intelligence assets came as such a
shock the depth of relations on matters
of politics security Military
Intelligence economics and religion Iran
should have taken all of this into
consideration it is totally unacceptable
to act
unilaterally the other elephant in the
room the 2500 strong us-led Coalition
Iraq often becoming the stage on which
the Rivalry between Iran and the United
States plays
out Iraq is struggling to stay out of
this fight it is very difficult the
least we can do to protect our own
interests is maintain a balance in
relations between the US and Iran the
whole situation is very complicated
especially amid the escalation of
fighting in the region we'll wait and
see two Wars occupation generations of
suffering and violence America's
indelible mark on Iraq is obvious
despite it all if you want to turn heads
in Bagdad it is usually from behind the
wheel of an American muscle
car people love American cars because of
the look they have big loud engines it
gives young people something to be proud
of like its ties to Iran Iraq's
relationship with the United States is a
LoveHate one as
well curfews blast walls and power Cuts
have given way to investment prosperity
and a degree of political Harmony new
shops and restaurants people out on the
streets the return of a vibrant night
life things in Bagdad are visibly
improving and Iraqis say that they're
learning to enjoy themselves once again
instead of just trying to
survive we want security and stability
we are against any external intervention
in our business I hope for the best for
my country so my children can leave in
peace there is progress but it is
delicate and Iraq's people agree on at
least one thing instability comes with a
real risk of
backsliding Zan basravi Al jaaz
B make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer